get
that's
there's
plenty the
[Music]
speaker
[Applause]
well we want to thank all of you for
being here today uh I want to thank all
of my colleagues for joining me here in
the epicenter of the uh of the crisis
that we're having On the Border here in
Eagle Pass Texas it's been quite a day
I'll tell you a little bit about uh what
we've learned here today uh but I first
I want to tell you that we have uh a
great cross-section of the of the house
we have 64 House of Republicans that
have joined us here in Eagle Pass they
represent 26 States one US territory you
have everybody from uh from from
California to Maryland from Michigan to
to Florida we we represent over half the
US states because every state in America
is now a border state and we've seen
that on Vivid display today today we
were able to meet with local residents
with sheriffs with the Texas DPS we also
toured the CBP processing facility here
in Eagle Pass and it's been an eyeopener
one thing is absolutely clear America is
at a Breaking Point with record levels
of illegal immigration and today we got
a firsthand look at the damage and the
chaos the Border catastrophe is causing
in all of our communities the situation
here and across the country is truly
unconscionable we would describe it as
both heartbreaking and infuriating our
communities are overrun we have local
resources that are being strapped we
have lethal drugs that are pouring into
our country at record levels and it's in
less than 3 years that President Biden
took office that this has happened that
we have over 7 million illegal
encounters at the border nearly 2
million known guideways and that doesn't
count the many that are
undetected at 312 Suspects on the
terrorist watch list that have app been
apprehended we have no idea how many
terrorists have come into the country
and set up terrorism cells Across the
Nation last month alone we saw the most
illegal Crossings in recorded history it
is an unmitigated disaster a catastrophe
and what's more tragic is that it's a
disaster of the president's own design
about an hour ago we uh had lunch and
and there were a number of sheriffs that
uh work and serve here along the border
of Texas the sheriff of Terrell County
was one of them he was a former border
patrol agent for 26 years and he said in
his estimation it took less than six
months for the Biden Administration to
dismantle 100 years of progress that the
US border patrol had achieved some of of
the first actions that Joe Biden took
when he uh rolled into the Oval Office
were that he rolled back border security
measures they were put in place by the
Trump Administration we all saw it
happen remember it was on his very first
day in office that President Biden
stopped construction of the Southern
border wall and he ended the remain in
Mexico policy it was estimated on our
tour just a moment ago that if the Biden
Administration would reinstate just the
remaining Mexico policy it could stem
the Flow by probably 70% or more but he
ref refuses to do it and since the time
that President Biden took office the
Administration has done next to nothing
to protect the Border but we've all seen
with our own eyes they have opened the
Border wide to the entire world it's
estimated that nearly 170 countries have
people coming in and flowing across this
border and some of these are from
Nations uh that that uh have high
numbers of concentration and these are
these are not uh people who are fleeing
and looking for Asylum that are in fear
for their lives in their home countries
uh we have hardened criminals coming
across that border they're the ones
being released from prisons from some of
these countries and sent here to come
into the US rather than incentivizing
people to come the president needs to
deter people from entering the country
rather than discussing amnesty with
Mexico as top Biden Administration
officials did within the last couple of
weeks this Administration should
reinstate the Romania Mexico policy as
was said rather than expanding Parole
Authority to an unprecedented scale the
President should obviously end Catch and
Release and stop the abuse of our parole
and Asylum systems the president can and
should act now this doesn't require
legislation it requires leadership and
and despite the White House's claim he
has all the authority he needs right now
under existing federal law to stop this
madness but the message his policies has
sent is the opposite of that it's quite
clear under President Biden America has
laid out a welcome man to illegal
immigrants Smugglers and cartels he is
respons responsible for the grave threat
to our national security and our and our
nation's sovereignty that these policies
have created but instead of taking
responsibility and providing leadership
this Administration has done nothing but
attack elected officials who are trying
to fix this catastrophe the people
standing behind you have worked hard we
passed our legislation more than seven
months ago you have red and blue States
all across this country that are being
forced to step up because the federal
government has failed to do its job
right here in Texas governor Abit has
heroically done more to enforce the law
than the president has and how has this
Administration responded they have sued
the state of Texas to stop their
deterrence efforts they have brought
them to court to to strike down their
ability to put up uh booys in the water
and and razor wire and the rest it's
absolute Insanity the house has done its
job as I mentioned we delivered uh
Common Sense legislation that will
secure our border but it's been sitting
on Chuck Schumer's desk for seven months
house resolution 2 was our was our our
bill and the time to act on it is
yesterday it certainly needs to happen
with each passing day each record broken
this administration's dereliction of
Duty comes more becomes more and more
dangerous and more and more infuriating
and we are here to say that it must stop
what we saw today only made House
Republicans more resolved to stand for
sanity and the American people and we
will do it if President Biden wants a
supplemental spending Bill focused on
National security it better Begin by
defending America's national
[Applause]
security it begins right here on a
southern border we have a a few members
here that will give you some more
insight on what we saw today and what we
anticipate and I'll I'll lead off next
with the chairman of our homeland
security committee Mark green of
Tennessee Mark
chairman I want to thank the speaker for
uh putting this codell together really
appreciate it thank you for all uh
coming it's important to
bring uh what's happening here to the
American people to all of the American
people I also want to thank the members
who are here you know I first took the
oath to defend the Constitution of the
United States against enemies foreign
and domestic on the plane at West Point
when I was 17 years old and for the
better part of my adult life I have
spent that training and fighting foreign
terrorists and now as a chairman of the
committee on homeland security I contend
with the domestic threats to this
nation the greatest domestic threat to
the National Security and the safety of
the American people is secretary
Alejandro
mayorcas he through his policies has
defied and subverted the laws passed by
the United States Congress he has defied
multiple court orders he has lied
numerous times to the United States
Congress he has under oath stated things
that were
blatantly obviously
incorrect he has broken his oath to
defend this
country even AG Garland admitted that
the policies of mayorcas are being used
used by the cartels to exploit the
American people and make billions of
dollars putting Americans at risk
hundreds of thousands Americans dead to
fenel tens of thousands of young people
trafficked into sex
slavery billions of dollars
wasted expanded criminal networks now
connected to the drug cartels in Mexico
throughout our entire
country director Ray admitted before my
committee the other day our committee
the other day that with the Border wide
open and a war in Israel Hamas can just
walk right
in that's the director of the
FBI he fears for his own
agents it's clear this is
intentional secretary mayus knows the
policies if the AG knows the policies
are the cause secretary mayorcas knows
the policies are the cause he's doubling
down he's doing this
intentionally despite the catastrophic
harm to our
country well our committee has finished
its five-phase investigation I want to
thank the members of the committee for
their hard work in our staff you're
going to see a lot more coming here very
soon I'm going to let my colleagues talk
about the numbers because I I get to
talk about them all the time um I want
to spend my time my two minutes this
morning telling you that the cause of
the problem is Alejandro
mearis thanks again to the speaker for
putting this together the members for
coming every state and city in this
country is a border state but I want to
say a special thank you and salute to
Texas you have borne the brunt of this
and we we will not let you down
accountability is coming I promise and I
will be followed by the amazing chairman
of the Judiciary committee Jim
Jordan thanks uh thanks Mark and I too
want to thank the speaker I want to
thank all the people in law enforcement
that we got a chance to interact with
today yeah that's that's that's kind of
what we we we all know how serious this
problem is so I would just say this I
think there are the country understands
the magnitude of the problem but I think
there are three fundamental questions we
got to ask what's the cause what is the
true magnitude of this problem and then
what's the solution we all know the
cause the speaker said this the cause is
the policies of the Biden Administration
and they frankly decided on day one
January 20th 2021 when he took the off
office they decided that day no more
building the wall no more remain in
Mexico and they were going to release
people who came to the country and that
became the incentive for so many
millions to come to our great country
the magnitude of the problem you've all
heard the numbers but I just point to
two last month record month 300,000
illegal migrants come into the country
the pace the Biden Administration in his
in his term as president will will reach
12 million when they're done and I tell
people that's the equivalent that equals
the population of the state I'm from the
great state of Ohio seventh largest
state that's the pace we're on that's
how big this problem is then finally
what's the solution the solution is to
go back to the policies that worked the
solution is our legislation or the
solution is simply I think one sentence
no money can be used to process or
release into the country country any new
migrants to just say suspend it now
which the president can do but if he
won't do it we should put that one
sentence in must pass legislation that
to me is how it finally I would just say
this I think in the end it boils down to
the will of Republicans in the United
States Congress are we going to force
that sentence that Solution on a piece
of legislation to get this done that
should be our charge if we don't then
we're going to have to wait then we're
going to have to wait for the
presidential election and hope that
president Trump is our is is the new
president we're we can get back to the
policies at work it's that basic in my
judgment with that I would yield to the
gentleman I think from the home District
here Mr
gonzale showing uh showing up matters uh
whether you're a dog whether you're a
cat whether you're a member of Congress
whether you're the media showing up
matters and I want to thank uh the
speaker for uh for making this happen I
want to thank the speaker's team for
being season veterans and putting this
all together I want to thank my own team
this is our 24
21st uh border codell and I want to
thank our our team for uh for working
together with the speaker's office to
put this together I want to thank the
members that have all you know traveled
to get here two days after the holidays
we could all be doing different things
but we are united in making sure House
Republicans uh top priority is secure in
this border and that's shows that shows
by us being here and oh by the way two
weeks ago there were 12,000 people
coming over illegally under that bridge
to uh right down the street there was
thousands of people in the Firefly
facility that we visited earlier today
that has a max capacity of 1,000 people
there were 6,000 people there were 4,000
people that were getting released we
were at the brink of massive uh Catch
and Release and when that happens our
communities get turned upside down and
it's it may start here in Eagle Pass but
then it it quickly uh reaches San
Antonio and then it quickly reaches all
over the country well guess what today
that stopped now it may have to do with
the the fact that the speaker and 60
plus members showed up but it stopped
and the biggest part is
1,400 border patrol agents today are not
processing migrants that have come come
into our country legally they are out
into the field doing their damn job and
that's what I'd argue we are we are
fighting for the hardest we want border
patrol agents to get back to doing their
job how do we fix this we end Catch and
Release how do we fix this we Deport
people that are here illegally by the
thousands not by the dozens and then and
then if you stop talking for one second
and you just listen like we did today if
you hear from the Ranchers if you hear
from the sheriffs if you hear from the
judges the Mayors the people that live
here every day they will tell you the
same thing and the Nexus is this you
want to get the root of the issue the
root of the issue is the cartels the
cartels turn it on and they turn it off
and today is a prime example of that so
I have pushed it is long time for us to
label cartels as terrorist
organizations I will I will end with
this once again showing up matters I'm
grateful for the people that have shown
up I believe now is the time to to make
sure America is safe and we do that by
taking a down payment on border of
security in 24 with this team and we
come back for the rest when we win back
the White House in
25 with that I'll turn over I'll turn it
over to my good friend and colleague
from Texas Beth
vany thank you Tony I appreciate all the
work that you have done over the last
two three years that you have been in
Congress you have really taken this this
issue you have shown that you care
you've come down here with Solutions I
want to thank the speaker and his team
for recognizing this is a priority this
is a priority in our country this is a
priority for cities and states all
across our country and I come here not
only as a Texas representative but also
as a former Texas Mayor that took on
this issue head on we worked and we
partnered with immigrations and Customs
Enforcement we had more criminal illegal
aliens Deport uh deported from my city
during the time that I was mayor than
any other city in the country per capita
and what we found was we had decreased
crime almost overnight we became the
fifth safest city in the country because
we actually followed and enforced our
laws we were criticized by Sanctuary
cities across the country who are now
starting to feel what happens when you
have illegal immigrants come into your
into your city you can't handle the
resources you don't have it whether or
not it's housing School infrastructure
health care they're finally hearing it
they're finally seeing it and they're
finally speaking out about it we had an
opportunity today to talk to several
local elected officials to several
sheriffs what they told us is we are not
dealing with an immigration Pro problem
we are dealing with a sex trade problem
we are dealing with a cartel issue this
is where your focus needs to be when you
have women who are brought into this
country who are being treated as slaves
who are still in in inh in Holden
emboldened by Cartel members that takes
13 to 18 years potentially to be able to
work off their debt that is what we are
seeing under a Biden Administration you
have had a 100,000 children come into
this country and they've lost we have
absolutely no idea where they are how is
this possible and how under our
governance is this happening I will tell
you another thing that they were very
clear about was we implore you and this
is a quote hold the line you have the
ability through your your power of the
purse to force this Administration to do
its job it's sad that you have to do
that but that is exactly the position
that we find ourselves in hold a line
none of us want to shut down the
government but we all recognize the fact
that every single penny that we are
giving to Homeland Security at this
point that is not being used to secure
our border that is not being used to
increase our national security but is
doing the exact opposite is weakening it
it is forcing more and more people
quickly more efficiently into our
country illegally is hurting our
national security hurting our best
interest and killing our economy and
local and local governments when you've
had over a 100,000 people that have been
killed as a result of fentanyl more than
any other terrorist attack on our
country this is a time to take steps
this is a time to to hold the line and
we in Congress we have a we have a bill
hr2 and I could not agree any more
strongly with representative Gonzalez
that we do have to Target their cartels
but we have a job to do the American
people are absolutely sick of the
policies that they've seen under the
Biden Administration and we will hold
the line and we will fight to make sure
hr2 is passed as well as other border
security measures that will support our
Customs and Border Patrol and help
secure our nation thank you and with
that I want to introduce Juan CIS goani
great state of
Arizona thank you thank you all for
being here I wanted to thank the speaker
for his leadership on this issue I
wanted to thank my colleagues for coming
to the southern border and seeing for
themselves what we've been talking about
for so long and of course thank my good
friend Tony Gonzalez for hosting us here
in this District as he continues this
fight uh against uh uh the Border crisis
that we're seeing I'm an
immigrant came to this country when I
was 11 years old became a US citizen in
2006 as an adult in my
20s then I was elected to the United
States Congress 16 years
later no country in the world would give
you that opportunity no country in the
world only America would ever give you
that opportunity so I believe in the
opportunity this country has I believe
in the generos of our
nation I believe in the American dream
that I'm
living but this is not it that's not it
with this crisis that Joe Biden and
Alejandra mayorcas have created nobody
wins nobody wins except the cartels
they're the ones deciding who gets
across and who doesn't they're the ones
trafficking people and drugs they're the
ones terrorizing their own
citizens
they're the ones that have no regard for
human
life the men and women that we met with
today fighting on the front lines for
our safety are doing so with very little
to no support from this Administration
trying to enforce policies that are at
best outdated at worst designed to fail
because they're not working and the
right ones are not being enforced you've
heard here today and we've been saying
this for years that every state has
become a border state
in my own state in Arizona in the Tucson
sector we saw record-breaking numbers in
December the trend is in the wrong
direction this Administration has no
answers and no will to tackle this issue
this is not a political matter this is a
matter of security and
sovereignty and I see some Spanish
stations here so I'm going to address
you in Spanish as
well
[Music]
B
it's important to know that as an
immigrant myself and I can say that this
situation is like with many other
families that it took us over a decade
to earn our
citizenship and what the Biden
Administration has done they've diluted
the effort the focus and the sacrifice
of so many families that have paid the
ultimate price of leaving their country
to come here and go through a long
rigorous process to become US citizens
and be able to take that oath of
citizenship like I did in
2006 and this
Administration with their actions has
made a fool out of that
process and it's spit in the face of so
many that have gone through the entire
process to one day have the honor of
becoming United States citizens this
message transcends culture this message
transcends language this is an American
issue that we must solve from every
perspective that you see reflected here
behind us our GOP colleagues get it our
Speaker gets it and we will solve this
issue and the president needs to step up
and do his part along with Alejandra
mayoras thank you so much Mr
Speaker I want to thank my uh colleagues
and friends again for being here and and
sharing you that Insight we'll take a
few questions if you have
something we're not going to do show
we're not in a classroom we're not doing
show well here's the here's the deal on
the on the shutdown we we are working
hard to uh get the Appropriations bills
done and the resolve that of this group
and that you've seen with our votes and
in carrying over and crushing the
Christmas Omnibus fever as we did with
our laded approach in the twep CR we
have until mid January you have until
early February to get the approach bills
done we have been working in Earnest and
in good faith with the Senate and the
White House virtually every day through
the holiday trying to come to an
agreement negotiations are still ongoing
it's drug on way too long but the sooner
we get that agreement the sooner we'll
be able to get the Appropriations bills
done and let me tell you what our top
two priorities are right now in summary
we want to get the Border closed and
secured first and we want to make sure
that we reduce non-defense discretionary
spending that is an important objective
you know why because we've crossed the
threshold of $34 trillion do in debt $34
trillion today it's a landmark that is
unimaginable would have been
unimaginable to previous generations and
here we are and so we have a
responsibility here of fiscal
stewardship and fiscal sanity and that's
the priority that you're going to see us
pursue so too early to prejudge any of
that but I'll tell you we're resolved on
those priorities Mr Speaker do you do
you have you've been briefed on these
negotiations with the Senate what is
your view of them right now and are they
going as far as you need them to go to
with regard to border security yes
listen the the Senate has been uh
negotiating I guess among members there
and and potentially with the White House
I suppose we our position is very clear
and we have made that uh clear again for
seven months hr2 is the necessary
ingredient why because it has Provisions
that fix each of these problems and
these things work together for example
you couldn't just reform the broken
Asylum process and allow this parole
system to remain broken it would be a
giant loophole that would not solve the
issue you can't just build the the wall
without ending Catch and Release without
restoring remaining Mexico these are the
the policies and the provisions that
again had stemmed the flow in the
previous administration we know what
works it's not rocket science and that
is why we have said we are resolved for
those Provisions that's what's necessary
to fix the problem it's not just House
Republicans opinion it's based upon the
informed opinions of the people here on
the ground and that is what they have
told us and they have reiterated this
over and over and over desperately they
ask us to help them solve this problem
not just for South Texas but for the
entire country and that's why you see
representatives from all across America
here to say in one voice that we have to
do this for the people and the White
House has shown an unwillingness to do
it in fact as we noted they've done
exactly the opposite and it's shameful
and inexcusable yes
ma'am aslum we saw2
en
going I can tell you it's a very
complicated complex issue just finding
those people you heard representative
van Dy say earlier tragically nearly a
100,000 undocumented uh uh children who
were unaccompanied who came across the
border unaccompanied miners have been
lost into the system the the the
Administration has lost track of these
children after they've been released the
these people are giving a notice to
return for an immigration hearing
sometimes it's four years into the
future they don't show up a very tiny
percentage show up so the first problem
would be even identifying all these
people the point is the longer we wait
the longer we delay the closure and
securing of this border the greater the
crisis and the problem we don't have a
specific prescription uh yet that we're
proposing because we haven't gotten to
that point but I do believe in large
measure because of this issue I do think
that we're going to have a change in the
white house I think we're going to have
a Republican president I think we're
going to win the Senate and we're going
to expand the majority in the house as
[Applause]
well absolutely listen we have applauded
Governor Abbott and all the brave law
enforcement officers here on the border
in Texas they're doing their dead level
best to protect their citizens and
that's his number one job the federal
government the White House the
administration refuses to do it so if
you're the governor of Texas or a border
state or any Governor you have the
responsibility the right the
Constitutional authority to do the right
thing and secure your people so we have
applauded him we stand with him in that
resolve and any other governor who's
willing to draw the line and take that
measure and remember everything they
triy to do the White House has gone to
court to stop everything they're trying
to do to protect Texans the the White
House is going to take them to court and
and have it undone it's it's Madness is
the only word that we can think of to
describe this and we hope it trees and I
don't know it comes to an end soon and
we're here to make sure that happens
thank you all for being here God bless
thank
you thanks buddy apprciate man
thank brother appreciate
appreciate
am
yeah okay
put
oh would
you
a
the
eat your
I don't
know
yeah I mean I don't know
it's
kind I'm not
a
thank
come on let's get on with
it
what is what you
told what is what you told the
truth significant threat we fa today is
an unsecured internal border of
Mexico right
hey
guys
say the same 10
weeks
traffic 9s they hooked up with kic the
colians
outan that's what
really
that
power
hey notice hey our border is a
river
approaching
they do that same thing
so we're in Del Rio Texas speaker Mike
Johnson
DPS exactly what's going on we're
bringing in school district about 10 a
week to teach all these young kids
coming in M bring in health needs where
going to hospital babies and all the
stuff that we're paying with taxpayer
this has to
stop this
dud
what was
that I'm I'm shooting video
from who who you who
you okay no I'm I'm the ground crew I'm
the the b roll
crew all right that's Lorenzo you need
Lorenzo
got it
we
com
we can't let this happen you can't tell
me this man cares about black and brown
people and they continues to allow
slavery to run ramp on the we have to
stop we have to stop it now and we will
hold by the
administration
once they touch the banks they're on us
soil and obviously from a state
standpoint we wanted DET tour them the
closer you can get the infrastructure to
the water the better off even better if
it's in the in the water buoys and
they're not touching us soil at that
point in time and it also prevents the
it eliminates their opportunity to use
the boats people don't realize while
people are coming across walking across
they're launching boats at other
locations so they'll be apprehended now
that's they'll be
apprehended and uh then what happens to
well it depends if if we if this is a
location we've got uh the city is is is
authorized we'll charge
TR and then we'll go through the St
process
with the state system we'll turn them
back over to board Patrol afterwards and
Ice they'll be processed with
en heyy and by the way I mean they do
what the cartels tell them to do to
You'll watch you'll see Scouts along the
other side of the banks and they'll
direct them and they'll tell them when
to go and and many cases especially when
they've got large groups of women and
children they'll tell them hey you can't
they don't stay you just stay there they
want them to stay there as long as they
can
exactly hey the only one that benefits
in this Mass migration event has been
Mexican cartels yeah play they become
enriched empowered more so than they
ever were before they were